all right so hi we're here tonight we
are talking to Donnie Palmer of
Massachusetts who's running for United
States Congress against Squad member
Ayanna Presley and
I'm going to just tell you real quick
before I let you really introduce
yourself Donnie why we're doing this
here on our Channel where you know we
have reaction videos we have opinion
videos this is the first time we're
talking to a candidate and we're sitting
it we're doing it from Florida okay my
son already bounced from Massachusetts
and is an official Florida resident I
just moved I still have my home in
Massachusetts but we just moved down
here not sure if it's permanent or
temporary I'm still a Massachusetts
resident and Massachusetts is my home it
has been for 23 years and I love it but
the way this country is going I'm
deciding whether or not to give up my
mass residency and and become official
you know here in Florida and I care very
deeply about the people there and the
state and I'm nauseous over the way it's
been going so that's one thing I want
full transparency I don't want anybody
to say this this lady doesn't even live
in Mass anymore yeah well it's still my
home and I'm gonna come back as long as
it doesn't continue to go to hell in a
hand basket so that's where we're at we
also have this audience 90 men what 18
to 32 years old is our primary audience
and I want them to be able to see
this conversation that as a regular
person with no influence
no law degree that we can have a
conversation about the law and we can
dig a little deeper and understand how
our Congress people actually do affect
our lives so I like what you stand for I
like what you're doing and can I just
give you the floor to introduce yourself
and tell us why you're running and a
little bit about your background because
you're kind of a badass right I mean
that's what we're here
thank you thank you um well my name is
Donnie Palmer I was born and raised in
Roxbury Mass
little Roxbury which is now
thing but it's all going straight
um I grew up there when the Army when we
had an L training in Boston with the
orange line was the L train you know
it had a bridge it ran on the bridge
and uh the shout that was ugly no one
would drop me off past no one would
cross them only a cast to drop me off
you know no one would ever crossed my
leader guys yeah a tough neighborhood
yeah it was a tough day but like that's
where I grew up uh it's changed now uh
uh my mom and dad are from Honduras
first generation they came here legally
you know they did the right way they
swore into the oath uh took a test
you know my mom is an army veteran also
uh my dad was a cab driver before Uber
put them out of business you know he had
a medallion you know he wearing two cabs
drove caps like 15 like 30 40 years
actually until he died
you're an army veteran yourself right
almost uh I used to be a special ed
school teacher before I lost my job for
refusing to teach brokerage Theory and
to wear a mask you know teaching
especially kids with the mask that's
abuse because so so can you dig into
that just for a second for so you were
teaching in Massachusetts you refused to
teach critical race Theory and you were
fired can you just expand on that a
little bit
well uh in August before school starts
teachers come back to PD right uh we go
back for pde justice to see a new
curriculum look at them look at the
reunion contracts through laws you know
it's just a rundown on
on how to how how the year is going to
go you know so itinerary of how the
years gonna go so that we started
telling us you know
um huh and uh it's a critical Race 3 was
coming in and then it was like okay I
don't really believe in this diversity
Equity inclusion stuff and this stuff
social justice stuff you know where they
have to sign up for those children I
didn't want to do it I didn't believe in
it
hmm you know I said I wouldn't teach a
kid differently from a black kid a black
kid different from why can't you teach
them all the same you know how to read
how to write how to count enough and if
that's not what I'm doing and that's not
teaching it I don't want to you know and
then I won't sign this contract well
then you can go over and leave and
you'll have to talk about it all right
cool it will be I'll leave and you never
got to call me back you know yeah was
that a Massachusetts Public School
yes Boston Boston Public School okay wow
that's wild I don't know how I'm just
hearing about that yeah I mean I went to
Boston Latin and that school was so
liberal it was insane
what'd you say yeah BLM everywhere oh my
God I remember I left the school but a
year after George Floyd died they had a
moment of like when the whole school was
on a zoom they had a moment of silence
for like the one year of George Floyd
it was crazy I remember they were the
non-stop when was the last time they had
a moment of silence from Martin Luther
King you know moving on a real a real
hero they used to have every year like
one of those climate days or like change
days where kids would put their most um
their their biggest issue on their shirt
and I remember one girl like these kids
are so uneducated and the teachers
didn't even stop them she had a shirt
that said allow trans people to have
babies and I was like you realize like
if you go to a girl you can't just like
have a baby right and she was like
defending defending that in other
countries they're just not allowed I was
like what do you talk
like that in other countries they just
don't
they'd be killed like I don't get it
like okay
I don't get it I don't get these
liberals okay
in other countries right right Muslim
countries
seriously you know they kill gays they
they throw them off they make them off
the plank right and then they're
advertising
for these people to come here and not
assimilate to our country and they're
wondering why crime rates and rapes are
so high
in certain parts of the country like
dead woman like in Michigan and you know
uh New York you know
yeah you have to people have to
assimilate to our culture
and there's nothing wrong with that it
works there's parts of us that and what
I when I grew up I grew up in Brooklyn
right so we had neighborhoods all
different culture I grew up in an
Italian and Jewish neighborhood
primarily it was those two things
there's a couple other sprinkled in and
you know what we we loved each other's
food we went to the you know we went to
the the Polish neighborhood for their
food we went to you know the Spanish
neighborhood for their food and and the
cultures were stronger but we all had
this Common Ground area where we were
Americans and it was cool you know and
cultures are actually stronger so this
diversity
thing is a misnomer because they just
want everybody to be the same but yet at
the same time all they do is label us
different it's all just it's all
nonsense it's nonsense and it's
exhausting and there's not one good
result BLM has not produced one positive
result for the black community not one
I've I've searched for it and I can't
find it they bought some Mansions they
bought themselves some Mansions yeah
yeah they're right yeah there was a
couple black families living pretty
large but 90 million dollars they didn't
give a dollar out to any black
businesses were struggling
yeah that was that was crazy because I
remember during High School when a white
kid in my school called out on his
Instagram story that it was just feeling
was used for the election and it's
basically a scam and it was like
unacceptable to talk to him in school he
was like sitting alone at lunch and
stuff and I talked to him because I
didn't give a [ __ ] but it was wild to
see how much people hated on him for
that like everybody was so brainwashed
and even the schools would push this
[ __ ] Non-Stop and the schools the way
like they teach in the curriculums it's
like it's almost telling black people
that they're still oppressed like they
they talk about redlining and stuff like
that that happened years and years ago
and yeah it's good to like recognize
that stuff happened but the way they
teach it it's almost to like make you
feel bad like the white kids feel bad
and then the black people feel like
they're still oppressed and they still
have to fight against the government
when at the end of the day we're all
fighting against these corrupt idiots at
the top anyways it's like you think
black white any of this matters like
it's all I say that it's all broken
stuff like if you're worried
I think all parents
should follow
what's your father child abuse because
child abuse it's it's childish so for
white children it's child abuse on black
children
because what happens is you're going to
get you got white kids grouping up with
each other you know because
that's what CIT makes you do in school
makes you group up you start reading
this stuff and group up you're like wow
you start feeling awkward you know it
just makes the
makes the atmosphere uncomfortable
yeah yeah and they'll say that's what we
need we need it to be on people need to
feel uncomfortable no we don't we need
to we need to go back to not labeling
each other and just being nice to each
other that's what we need and we need to
keep I'm with you so I have this takes
me just to a point I wanted to make
about division right it's perfect
perfect segue so division in this
country the old say the old you know us
motto united we stand divided we fall
it's more than just empty words and
we're seeing it in action right now that
they have us from the top the media the
politicians they've got us divided and
arguing over dumb [ __ ] down here like
pronouns and you know and skin color so
that they can just continue in my
opinion to operate and do the things
that they do behind the smoke screen
they have us divided so much when I
listen to Ayanna Presley every single
speech there is not one I can find of
her where she does not talk about race
and oppression and race and oppression
and this and it's US versus them and she
is so divisive and she is not helping
the black community she hasn't done a
goddamn thing to make their lives better
in fact like we just talked about she
wants to take before we came on screen
we were talking about how she wants to
take out metal detectors and police from
schools so that there is no safety net
for teachers and schools so let me just
what are you hearing on the street about
all this division from black people that
you're talking to and and from white
people and as a congressperson like what
are you gonna do to to help calm this
and bring some Unity back because this
is exhausting for us out here
the first thing I'm going to do is do
away with di boards in all the schools
diversity Equity inclusion
like like I'm getting my heart's getting
warm thank you really truly so getting
out of everybody who's a DI officer or
whatever you think you are with
fatalities that doesn't even
doesn't exist in Boston in district 7
anymore I'm sorry you know
um I want to do critical race steering
out of schools I mean
all right you know that's the first
thing we gotta start at the bottom
they're trying to doctor and doctorate
our kids at the Grassroots and now
they're trying to put in that Universal
daycare you know which is taking the
kids out of the mom and pop daycare and
putting them on the public school bus
the senatorial Market School at two or
three years old that's crazy can you
imagine your kid getting on a freaking
yellow school bus in Dorchester at three
years old these kids got guns nods they
smoke weed on the bus they got nips
they're drinking it right before they
get before elementary school before they
get to to First Class they're on the bus
you understand having sex on the bus and
you want your two three-year-old witness
that really no no and then go to school
and being told that they're not good
enough because of the color of their
skin and their you know and somebody's
some you know everyone's gonna hold you
back and making them angry and keeping
us divided that's what they I used to
think you know there was a part of me
that understands why someone would think
that Early Education free Early
Education would be good for a working
family to help them out but it doesn't
help them out it just is creating
another generation of angry uneducated
kids that's what they want we need to
take back our school systems that's the
first thing I want to do when I get
accomplished because like I said such
the Grassroots got to take back our
school systems re-educate our kids
differently right and give them all
trade skills tell them colleges you got
to tell them colleges
of financial Guru you buy a truck you
buy one truck you hire two friends and
three years you buy two trucks you have
one friend body up you can drive the
other truck and another year you buy
three trucks you buy another truck all
you can find the driver trucks
management trucks you know you're making
sense you're making sense
foreign
for our culture right now we have no
respect for our own American culture
right now we have to get that back but
we're going to get that back in schools
start plating to Allegiance you know
every morning you know you know I mean
just the simple stuff do they still do
that in schools the Pledge of Allegiance
just do not old schools some teachers do
it that's crazy I remember when I was in
BLS in seventh grade it was like the
start of some people sitting down
seventh and eighth grade some people
would sit down for it so it's weird I
remember always everyone standing and
you remember in seventh grade when we
all had to go we were me and two other
classrooms had to go to the auditorium
and listen to a BLM speech and they were
telling us about how the police are bad
and and but yes I went nuts
I wrote a diatribe letter to the school
I went nuts on that one uh we got to
pull that up one of these days yeah that
was crazy though like seventh grade
they're bringing us in and the people
that are supposed to like you I you
almost idolize your teachers when you're
younger not like to Aspire to be them
but you look at them as such an
authority figure and like your word
means a lot because like I'm here to
learn from you and they know that and
that's why they're pushing all their
[ __ ] and then I got older and I'm
working at the the local restaurant and
like a lot of my old teachers come in
and just hearing them talk outside of
school I was like these people are
idiots idiots like this is who I was
like stuck with in like third grade like
let me let me yeah you're so right I
wanna I wanna go back to something you
were talking about about education so
you know I just got myself on Twitter
recently you know I got like 130
followers nobody knows I'm there
I'm already following you I'm already
following you yeah you follow follow
back all right so uh we so it just start
I just started right and one of the
things that I am
really adamant about and I'm saying this
to you as a future Congressman
um
I subscribe to the the just old adage
that if you give a man a fish you feed
him for a day if you teach him Manta
fish you feed him for a lifetime and
again I believe that the United States
government wants us dumb and compliant
so I want to change education where we
teach a man to fish teach us all to fish
and I want financial literacy I want
federally funded I want money for every
school in America from kindergarten up
to 12 to have financial literacy that is
age-appropriate where they learn how to
do everything saving investing just
balancing a basic checkbook whether you
are a dishwasher for the rest of your
life because that's where your your your
your cap in life is that's fine but you
should learn how to manage your money
and if we did that we would be able to
get out of the welfare state we would
have generational
stability in one in one generation we'd
have Financial stability in two three
generations we'd have Financial wealth
across the board and we get everybody
off of welfare and Welfare would be for
emergency cases only which is what it
was intended for instead of a lifestyle
and I am telling you this because I've
got your ear I've got you like you know
I've got you held here and I can and I
can get this but I would love to see you
go into Congress and fight for that
because that is what's going to help
people to be wealthy not more handouts
just keep giving them fish and then
they're just they're just slaves to the
government that's [ __ ] me teaching
kids how to fish us and I don't want to
say B but us teaching children how to
fish because I want to The Relic the
rhetoric as accomplishment for my
district I want to use Is Us
but I would use us so what I want us to
do for our children here I'm going to
teach them how to fish just give them
trade skills they we have every trade
unions here in Boston that's in the
world right elevators
bartender
NBA you know guys
in the camera Crews every units here so
if you movie unions are here
the kid doesn't get into a universal
trade let's let them do that you know
let's get them into those you know put
them on the right direction you know you
get them in their passport
like graduated high school they work for
that Union
you know that's tickling how to speak
that's us teacher actually how to fix
um I'll just make sure you're speaking
into your mic
um a little bit more it sounds a little
bit yeah you're a little muffled I can
hear you but it's gonna be hard in
replays it's good like that now
okay all right that's much better all
good but um but yeah you're right we've
got everything but if we're just
teaching kids that
you know well what please what let's
let's go there there's the college route
that as a nation we've been telling kids
they have to go to college and we've
been proven that it doesn't it doesn't
help it puts makes people broke uh
they're coming out of college they're
getting they're getting a third of what
uh someone in a trade is getting if they
go to work after going to trade school
and you know
right now everyone's just in this
victimhood mentality because they went
to these colleges and they got
indoctrinated and were told that every
you know that that every feeling they
have is the most important thing in the
world
what do you think about student debt
cancellation and how that is gonna
you know how it's affecting us already
but I think what I think I thought I
think I thought it shouldn't have
happened and I don't everyone was happy
again as a future Congressman uh I'll
work really hard never to let this
happen again this is what I am
it was a very admin on trade skills for
every every child's graduating out of
our district in Massachusetts hopefully
I'm not muffled or you can hear me good
um so
yeah trade school certainly could no
more college is needed like I said
before to To Be A Millionaire or be
super successful
uh all you need to do is have a
some elbow grease and hard work you know
you have to give children a plan write
down life goals life plans with them you
know we don't need mental health
counselors we need life coaches we need
mentors for these kids
opportunities yeah it runs a lot deeper
than like it's a lot more complicated
because I think that
I mean I mean I think that the school
was like pretty much an indoctrination
system to be quite honest where from the
start they teach you to think where as
an entrepreneur you need to be able to
to spend all of your time working on
yourself you need to be able to to
constantly seek self-improvement think
for yourself but I just don't think that
the school systems from the start teach
you to do that I think it always teaches
you to follow this exact little
curriculum and not have any problem
solving skills so I do think that it
runs a lot deeper than simple things
um like teaching kids to manage a
checkbook and stuff like that well I do
think that's a great start I think that
a lot of these kids are still stuck on
the ideology that they're never going to
make money without a typical job or
stuff like that
you're really smart young man 19 years
old wow like you're right because what
they say is
uh CRT and uh this curriculum that they
use now
uh comical curriculum it stops the
growth mindset you know it stops the kid
from having a growth mindset and as
people we need to be good just just
decent individuals you know we have to
have a World's mindset you know which is
to listen to someone's point of view and
just always be able to grab from it even
if it's BS and you don't like the person
you don't like what they've got to ever
have to say but one day they might have
something decent coming off their lips
you know screwing up their mouth
you just missed everything because of
your emotions you're so emotional you
don't like the person like it is like
the thing with Trump people are so
emotional they don't even like Trump
they don't even see the policies look at
the policies that he's written you know
basically yeah right so if you don't
have a broken mindset you're going to be
screwed over for the rest of your life
yeah a lot of that changed in 2015 I
think when Trump won because before that
there was a lot more
discuss like you were discussing with
the other side especially in school even
when they they taught us how to how to
look at articles and stuff you would
look at both sides you need three
sources from each side and then after
Trump won the whole media and everything
just shifted because they realized that
people can actually think for themselves
so now we have to attack them
emotionally and get them to play by
their emotions to do what they want so
now that's why they just convince
everybody Trump is like this evil racist
that just wants to kill all black people
like crazy she was never people
genuinely believed that like they think
that my point was a lot of the things
that people don't like Trump for is
stuff that he didn't even do wrong it
was stuff that the media told him and
took out of context so yeah if you don't
like Trump for his for some actual
things he said or policy he instated
then yeah that's fine but a lot of these
people still just don't like him because
he said Mexicans are rapists like he
just didn't say that it's just something
the media pushed the same thing that
they're doing with Andrew Tate now I
don't know if you know who that is but
they just wipe his platform off the face
of the Earth to try to push an agenda on
him but
it's not working it's like one of the
first times it's not
so you know that takes me to something
that a current event I'd love to get
your thoughts on because I am super
excited that Elon Musk purchased Twitter
and today is the day today's the day
that you know he's in he went in he got
rid of a bunch of the you know the high
Executives and he got rid of one of the
first ones he cut was the woman who made
the call to get rid of Donald Trump the
censorship you know this is true like
true fascism
in action or fascist uh
you know philosophy and action is
cutting off voices that you don't want
to hear and silencing and and running
the narrative so that's been going on so
as of today we we now have a free
Twitter
what do you think
I think it's awesome uh it was a girl
right the the Indian girl right yeah
it's like two two Indian execs I got cut
off
yeah it feels great I mean yeah she was
a tyrant she was tired
oh professor
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna just
up up the excitement here because I'm
telling you I am so excited about it
because people like you are going to be
able to come in and say
ask questions you know push push push
back on Congress and and really say
something without it being you know an
algorithm just pushing you off to the
side so nobody sees it because that's
what's you know what they've been doing
just like Facebook is coming out now
and they just said uh they're not
letting after November 2nd no one else
can put any more uh social social issues
or political issues that political adds
up which is crazy like Ohio
because they're getting scared now
because they're getting scared they're
gonna pull terrified they're terrified
they're gonna pull climate change or
some [ __ ] out of their ass
all right we're Lo we're losing you
Donnie you're gonna we're gonna ask you
to repeat what you just said please
yeah we're losing you I don't know
what's going on uh down there
yeah there you are there you are I think
it's just looking at the cat the
computer something is yeah weird about
okay I was just looking at the uh my
phone I'm sorry for the speaking Yeah
just we can't hear you if if uh if you
when you whatever you turn it right for
some reason we can't hear you so we want
to hear what you have to say
so I sent you guys a text look at your
text oh okay oh
here
that's what uh Facebook is doing right
now
to conservatives
well
maybe they'll be next
maybe the next maybe they'll be next to
to re-enter the world of Free Speech but
speaking of
let me ask you this is very important
because I want to have this
it's my understanding or I'm being I'm
being told that um you have offered uh
Ayanna Presley an opportunity to debate
you and she has refused
yes can you talk about that I want to
know like more specifically you know
have you reached out to her what has she
said or what has her Camp said for why
they won't debate
uh going to say John Moran John Paul
Moran of go USA uh which is uh go
opportunity
USA they do like uh Ops scores for every
political candidate it's basically like
a Yelp serviceable mechanics is amazing
um
so they did a debate for like they do
National debates for everyone they do
National debates for everyone they did
debate and uh
never got back to him
and uh they sent out emails and uh
I've never heard anything back
you know so she just denied to respond
to any everyone's uh requests to debate
well I think she knows that if she if
she debates you that you'll get you'll
get a lot of the attention and you're
going to take a lot of the votes
so that's you know so I'm gonna say if
she happens to see this
buck up because
there are there's the woman in Arizona
uh who is refusing to debate Kari Lake
um now Ayanna Presley is refusing to
debate you got to give it to John
frederman he looked really sad but he
got up and debated Dr Oz but he was
refusing to debate
um but there are there are a whole list
uh I don't have him in front of me of
candidates especially women who are
refusing debates and I gotta say to them
all I'm saying it right now loud and
clear you're out here pretending like
you're a super feminist and you're so
strong and you can handle anything you
can't even handle a debate get out there
prove it Ayanna get out get on the stage
with Johnny let's talk about it get out
here she respects black men right she
respects black men black the husbands
should probably debate me give you some
respect right she is not going to debate
you because
she knows that people are sick of it
people are sick of it and so I'm
challenging her to debate you I'll
challenge her to come on here yeah is
she gonna in some ways eat Us Alive
because she knows the system backwards
and forwards that's fine but when it
comes down to moral basis and what she's
actually accomplishing for the American
people and the people of Massachusetts
it's nothing she's hurting us she's
creating Division and I challenge her to
talk to you let's see if she can do it
she's not she's not because she's afraid
lunch
[Music]
and spit her out because
don't get me I'm saying mean [ __ ] now so
no it's Gotta she's gotta do it all
these women they're making women look
bad they want to make every they want to
say what leaders they are sorry leaders
get up they stand up they have the
conversation they put themselves in the
spotlight and she's afraid that's why
she's not debating you no matter what
she says no matter what excuses she
makes
so let's see it is you're right you're
correct let's see if she gets out there
you're ready right you better have your
suit ready you better be ready have that
shirt pressed because I'm telling you if
we can get this on it's on
I'm ready all right all right wait there
was we could talk to you all day but we
do we do have to wrap up
um I gotta go pick up Grandma at the
hospital
because that's life life is still here
but what what final thoughts do you have
what message do you want to get out this
is your chance we're gonna clip this up
we're gonna send it out to the world see
what we can do
tell us
I want to say you know this midterm
election is Big you know we have to
fight for our children our children are
at stake you know our economy is at
stake
you know our livelihoods are at stake
you know your mortgage is your house you
know he grew homes this winter
it went up from 179 last year to 293 a
month this year National Grid episodes
the full prices are up you know a bag of
girls two bags of groceries are running
a hundred bucks at Stop and Shop
yeah you know think about it people I
don't know
it's crazy they want
us dumb they want us uneducated they
want us unhealthy
you understand that they want us
dependent on them
we have to be Americans you know we have
to be free we have to be able to do what
we need to do do what we love to do make
money save money spend time with our
families they don't want us to do any of
that gas prices are high
how are you going to drive you don't
they don't want to they don't want us to
connect with each other you understand
they want us to be controlled they don't
want us to have love and connections
with each other okay how do you do that
and take away Transportation you make it
hard for people to be mobilizers and
Jazz look at the price of the gas look
at the price of a plane ticket
people can't people can't afford it
they're choosing between heat and food
this winter
like come on we have to change this this
is not America it's not working
yeah it's not working it's not working
at all
Marine hot dogs right everyone's going
to be down to Hot Dogs on Thanksgiving
it's really a sin no we will be eating
crickets in a couple of years at this
rate No but because because the cows
stay far and it's ruining the climate so
you know now we gotta no no no the New
York Times today put out an article that
said that climate that all the climate
alarmism uh that the world was coming to
an end so that oh yeah maybe we
exaggerated that so that again they
actually are admitting things now
in order to try to save the Democrats
same thing they did with covid so you
know
credit card
thing yeah
she she's a kid she's a kid you know an
emotional kid
all right listen you're a professional
boxer right
yes okay I'm gonna say this one more
time
Ayanna get in the ring we dare you
get in the ring with Johnny let's see it
on the debate stage
we're here for you we're gonna we're
gonna do what little we can and are in
our way to make sure that people know
that you're out there but you already
have my vote
thank you so much thank you so much we
have a round two follow-up all right you
guys got a lot more to talk about
so much all right all right
closing thoughts seraphino what do you
got I'm glad hopefully she won't call
you some racist names letter letter I'm
not a racist that's what they always do
you call me a racist all day long that
doesn't make me a racist I'm sick of it
well she can't call you white racist so
now they what do they they go to like
Uncle Tom and calling them no Donnie
Donny's a black white supremacist you
know oh the blacklight supremacist right
so we call them sambos
look it up
I live in the Urban Dictionary I spend
so much time with him I don't even I
don't know
that's what they are they stand bows
that's the uh you see the
Django yeah yeah
what's his name who's the uh the master
and the guy what was that guy's name
again oh excessively apologetic or
obedient black person and excessively
apologetic huh you don't seem very
apologetic
no what is
this oh Jackson
yeah oh okay he was he he was asleep but
who was on the slave owner's side
that's the symbol oh okay so that's what
you are yet they're calling you
think Uncle Tom is a [ __ ] they got it
mixed up like
oh Tom was the man he stayed the top
like how to read write how to make money
you know how to free themselves right
Uncle Tom was the man okay they got it
mixed up because they're idiots they
just they just repeat talking points
they don't dig
[ __ ] comes out of their mouth all right
they're both is who said well as Jackson
was dude that's that's what they are
they're samples
yeah well according to our president
you're not black if you don't vote for
him so I guess you're not black Donnie
says Joe Biden
what Madness what Madness that's okay
I'm not a woman either because I'm not a
an angry feminist so oh well
what are you gonna do I don't even know
what a woman is that definition
I know what a woman is
you don't want to do that I don't want
their definition or whatever the hell
that is
all right we're gonna talk again soon
I'm going to get Grandma
um thank you for thank you so much for
being here today
thank you Donnie
[Music]
[Music]